Welcome back everyone this is going to
be my brand new loki deleted scenes video
they revealed a whole bunch of deleted scenes
from episode 5 and from some earlier episodes
involving characters from episode five so we'll
break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos careful for spoilers from loki episode
5 and everything else that's happened on the show
so far if you haven't been watching the episodes
but the past few days you probably saw the loki
writers of producers have been revealing a bunch
of deleted scenes the biggest one being a deleted
scene with loki versus frog thor so in the actual
episode we saw there was a version of frog thor in
a jar labeled t-365 as they're sort of going down
into the bunker you see him trapped between layers
of dirt trying to escape from his little jar
you see a full-sized version of mjolnir in a whole
bunch of lunch trays but that was meant to be a
reference to the events of thor issue 365 which
was the big frog thor story this whole easter
egg is based on and the basis of thor's story from
thor ragnarok about loki turning him into a frog
that was the whole story that matt damon's fake
loki was telling during the play at the beginning
of the movie i'm a trickster yes so mischievous
sorry about that time i turned you into a frog
it was a wonderful joke it was indeed hilarious
the joke with frog thor in the void is that it's
a version of thor from those events when they were
younger where loki never changed him back into his
regular form but instead apparently trapped him in
a jar and then they both got pruned by the tva and
sent to the void the loki deleted scene with frog
thor vs thor actually was supposed to take place
during episode 1. if you can believe it according
to the producers they filmed a scene where mobius
is hauling loki into the time theater and showing
him all the footage from the marvel movies
but it winds up being a montage of failure of him
getting his ass kicked in every single time by the
avengers by thor and he's just using it to make
fun of him on purpose trying to get him to break
and lash out so that he can suss out what this
loki variant is all about the deleted scene of
loki vs frog thor was going to happen during the
humiliation montage of him showing him all those
scenes it was going to be another example of him
always losing no matter what he did as per mobius
as speech like what's going on are you the god
of getting your ass kicked it was basically tiny
frog thor pummeling full-sized loki with a tiny
frog sized mule near just kicking his ass up and
down but it's like a little tiny frog with a tiny
hammer doing it to a normal-sized tom hiddleston
loki so it was basically moebius showing us the
fans what actually wound up happening during matt
damon loki's story like another version of the
db cooper type of scene which was meant to be
an example of an adventure that the regular loki
had before he was killed in avengers infinity war
before this loki variant was created they didn't
say exactly when the frog thor scene was supposed
to happen in their timeline just at some
point before the events of the first thor film
but they had tom hiddleston performing his part
of the scene separately like on his own with some
motion capture references and then spliced it
together with the frog thor part because frog
thor is a pure special effect just like alligator
loki so you have to imagine tom hiddleston faking
getting pummeled by a tiny little frog and a tiny
little hammer as awesome as that sounds the reason
they said that they deleted the frog thor scene
is because the early part of this episode one with
them in the time theater felt like it was dragging
on in the edit bay and they knew that they were
going to do the frog thor easter egg later in the
void during episode 5 so they just opted to delete
it but the other really cool detail about frog
thor that the director just revealed is that the
version that we see in this series really is chris
hemsworth recording new dialogue for the scene
though it's not exactly what you would expect from
a chris hemsworth thor cameo i think the cooler
thing about this though is that any other regular
director or producer wouldn't have bothered to try
and get chris hesworth back just to record a bunch
of grunts for a frog trying to get out of a jar
so you have to imagine them pitching it to chris
hemsworth like we're going to bring you back to do
this special little scene it's going to be great
but it's going to be on a planet full of loki's
and get this you're going to be frog thor you son
of a i'm in and they didn't pay chris hemsworth to
do that either he just came back for free to be
a total dude just helping them out and because
it's just voice over grunting it was really easy
for him to do that remotely in australia where he
was while they were filming loki in the uk because
this was all happening during the lockdown period
last year i wasn't really thinking about chris
hemsworth when i watched this scene the first time
but if you re-watch it now and you listen you know
that it's chris hemsworth it does sound a little
bit like chris hemsworth grunts the next big
deleted scene they just revealed from episode 5
actually was happening at the end of the episode
during the big final battle so it was going to
be them fighting goliath but during the deleted
scene all of the loki variants that were left
in the void were going to rally and help our loki
and sylvie fight off a life and it was going to be
like an all loki version of the avengers assemble
scene from avengers end game like loki's assemble
which sounds hilarious and amazing at the same
time but the reason they said that that didn't
make it into the final episode is because they
didn't want it to diminish the triumph of our
loki learning to enchant on the fly and the two
of them defeating goliath by themselves realizing
that they could be much more powerful than anyone
gives loki's credit for that's what his little
speech about classic loki was when he was creating
that perfect illusion of his version of asgard
down to the trees and the cracks in the streets
he even added the detail of the lightning bolt as
a reference to his version of thor in our loki was
like we're stronger than people give us credit for
so as cool as the loki's assemble scene would
have been it would have kind of destroyed the
weight of that moment the head of production
the design the look of the void with all the
easter eggs and all the cool stuff all over
the place said that originally it was also
going to be way weirder inside the void i'm just
going to read his quote about it he said we were
trying to find moments to infuse the void with
surrealism so that was the point of the giant
heads that they were walking around all the time
and also the little void creatures that look like
little peacocks so if it wasn't clear those
weren't meant to be any specific reference i
was trying to find a comic book reference and
a couple people thought that they might have
been dodos or something like that but the way
the production designer explains it they were
just meant to be nonsense animals that weren't a
direct reference to any specific comic book thing
so he goes on to say originally at some point
i was proposing a far more salvador dali-esque
dada-esque version of the void and it evolved
over time but those little bird creatures and
heads made it through from the dada-esque version
of the english moors version of the void if you're
not familiar with salvador dali he was this really
famous spanish surrealist artist renowned for his
strange art pieces and paintings involving
melting clocks distorted landscapes dadaism
which was this really big european avant-garde art
movement from the early 20th century that focused
on nonsense and irrationality so originally
they were just going to have way more nonsense
happening in the void and it was going to look way
trippier you can kind of tell they're going for a
lot of deep cuts with their production design like
especially inside the timekeeper's room when they
go inside there it looks kind of like they walk
into an mc-escher painting where the staircases
are just going all over the place so i wouldn't be
surprised if they also do something really crazy
with the interior of the black citadel at the
actual end of time where the main villain has been
hiding this whole time we've seen a little bit
inside that black castle like loki walking through
the hallways that seem like endless hallways just
the way they're designed with the arches here
yeah the living room here even if you look on the
floor here too in the high resolution version of
this like zoom and enhance the symbol on the floor
kind of seems like some of the symbols that are at
the tva which i think is just meant to back up
the idea that the person who's been living here
this whole time at the end of time was actually
responsible for the original creation of the tba
as they've been theorizing this whole time on
the show the other big deleted scene that they've
revealed is actually at the very beginning of
the show at the very beginning of episode 1 it's
that avengers endgame scene the director kate
herron said that because they were building the
series off of that moment where loki escapes
in avengers end game they basically went into
the archives where they store all the footage
that they filmed and they were just petabytes
of footage that they didn't wind up using for
vendors end game just a whole bunch of really cool
deleted scenes in alternate versions of
scenes that we actually saw in the movie
so this whole opening scene with loki is basically
part of just an avengers endgame deleted scene
this is her quote about that she says it was
a lot of fun i mean what a treat as a director
getting access to the library of the rushes of all
these other brilliant filmmakers so basically they
said that they had access to all of the footage
from all the marvel movies that they filmed but
particularly from avengers end game then she goes
on to say that was the really fun thing with the
opening was getting to show that moment everyone
knows so well but from a completely different pov
just because the russo shot the scene a couple
different ways so as happened with falcon and
winter soldier with juan division we learned
about a lot of deleted scenes after the fact
especially from the finale so if we learn about
any really cool deleted scenes in loki episode 6
after it airs i'll do a video for that too of all
the marvel disney plus series so far i think the
series with the biggest like the most wtf deleted
scenes is still one division because of all the
plans that they had for benedict cumberbatch i've
already done a number of deleted scene videos for
that so i'll link some of them in the description
below because some of them are pretty crazy but
what's going to happen is my full loki episode
6 finale video we'll post on wednesday just like
normal i've got a new rick and morty episode 4
video that we'll post next so if you have any
big questions you want me to include in my bonus
videos this week just let me know in the comments
everyone click here for my loki episode 6 finale
trailer video and click here for my full loki
episode 5 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!